As we concluded, a radical change was needed a
brave new world. A completely new approach to building applications
needed to be developed that could scale to meet
the demands of the rapidly growing internet. Not a key
step to building a scalable system is you need
to decouple it from executing on a single computer. You
design a scale out architecture as your application scales
outside the scope of a single computer and this distributed
architecture needs to be a socalled, share
nothing architecture. Meaning, that it must not depend
on any shared resources that can become the
bottleneck, this way if your application needs a
scale, you can just provide more computers to
provide the additional capacity required. That means, you
can run your application on. All the things.
And to get even more flexibility the concept
of virtual machines was born which enables you
to decouple a physical machine from the application
execution machine. This had great flexibility gain since
the infrastructure turned virtual you would now run your
scale out application on several virtual machines instead
of physical computers. Problem solved, right? You can
now scale indefinitely by adding these standard building
blocks of performance that your application can utilize and
you have decomposed your application from the
specific execution machine, great. Now only one
question remains, how do you design your
application to be able to scale like this?